[Música]
Hola Esto es África 7 días en magazine
de la actualidad africana Mi nombre es
comenzamos con los titulares
estará Vladimir Putin presente en la
Cumbre de los bricks que se celebrará en
agosto en Sudáfrica Esta es la pregunta
en Boca de todos debido a una orden de
detención de la Corte Penal
Internacional que pesa sobre el
presidente ruso
en senegal usman sunco principal
opositor político del presidente
maquisal fue condenado a dos años de
cárcel por corrupción de menores El caso
es tan jurídico como político y provocó
manifestaciones que han dejado al menos
16 muertos y nos vamos a Río de Janeiro
para descubrir las obras de Maxwell
Alexander este artista brasileño Busca
exponer su obra fuera de los circuitos
elitistas y romper con el estigma
asociado a la representación de la
población negra en el arte
nuestros corresponsales Luis ole y
amiguidara le entrevistaron
pero empecemos con este rompecabezas
diplomático para Sudáfrica podrá el país
acoger a Vladimir Putin en la Cumbre de
los brics a finales de agosto los
ministros de asuntos exteriores del
grupo que incluye a Sudáfrica Brasil
China India y Rusia se reunieron en
Ciudad del Cabo Sudáfrica para preparar
la Cumbre de agosto que reunirá a los
jefes de estado del bloque en
johannesburgo uno de los temas que
dominó el encuentro fue el de la
asistencia o no de Vladimir Putin
su última reunión fue en 2019 la
pandemia de Kobe 19 había puesto un
freno a los encuentros del grupo pero
ahora que el virus ya no asusta a nadie
los ministros de asuntos exteriores del
bloque han aceptado la invitación de
Sudáfrica para preparar la próxima
reunión de sus jefes de estado que
tendrá lugar en johannesburgo en agosto
la eventual presencia del presidente
ruso Vladimir Putin marco la etapa
previa del encuentro de los diplomáticos
Sudáfrica que ostenta la presidencia
rotatoria de los brics evitó abordar el
tema en público no obstante suministra
de asuntos exteriores confirmó que el
presidente ruso sí había sido invitado a
pesar de la orden de detención dictada
contra él por la Corte Penal
Internacional como sospechoso de delitos
de deportación de niños ucranianos
no podemos permitir que un conflicto en
una parte del mundo sustituya la
ambición de erradicar la pobreza global
como el mayor reto mundial
desde el inicio de la guerra en Ucrania
el presidente ruso Apenas ha salido de
su país es suministro de asuntos
exteriores que viaja en su lugar cerré
lab también fue preguntado por la
posibilidad asistencia de Vladimir Putin
a la Cumbre de agosto se limitó a
elogiar al grupo bricks como alternativa
al orden mundial liderado por occidente
es una estructura diferente una nueva
organización basada en los principios de
igualdad respeto mutuo consenso no
injerencia y estricta adición a la carta
de la ONU a todos sus principios y a sus
vínculos recíprocos
Sudáfrica es miembro de la cpi y en
teoría debe de tener al presidente ruso
si entra en su territorio pero esta
posibilidad es inimaginable para
pretoria que mantiene estrechos lazos
con Moscú el gobierno sudafricano ha
creado un comité interministerial para
encontrar una solución a este
rompecabezas jurídico diplomático
invitar a Putin sin incumplir sus
compromisos internacionales y a la
espera de una solución a la
participación de Putin en la Cumbre de
agosto pretoria aprovecha su presidencia
rotatoria para promover los intereses
del continente el tema de este año es
África y los brics una asociación para
el crecimiento acelerado el desarrollo
sostenible y el multilateralismo
pasamos ahora a senegal donde las
tensiones políticas son máximas la
justicia condenado a dos años de cárcel
a usmansonco principal opositor político
del presidente maquisal después de que
una antigua empleada de un salón de
masajes presentará una denuncia contra
él por violación y amenazas de muerte
pero estos cargos no fueron confirmados
por el tribunal sin embargo este condenó
a sunco por corrupción de menores que es
un delito de incitacional libertinaje de
un menor de 21 años edad de la
denunciante en el momento de los hechos
tras conocerse El veredicto protesta se
estallaron Y al menos 16 personas
perdieron la vida escuchemos el análisis
de nuestra corresponsal a Sara sacó un
juicio político una justicia a las
órdenes del poder para Los partidarios
de Guzmán sunco su condena tiene un solo
objetivo evitar que se presente a las de
20 y 24 una pena de prisión de dos años
le hace perder su derecho civiles y por
lo tanto la posibilidad de presentarse a
las elecciones En definitiva los
manifestantes acusan al presidente
maquisal de querer eliminar a un serio
oponente para las próximas elecciones
Los partidarios de la oposición están
convencidos de que sal está preparando
el terreno para un tercer mandato si una
calma precaria ha vuelto a las calles de
Dakar el fondo del problema sigue sin
estar resuelto la policía retiene en su
casa oficialmente para mantener el orden
público su detención Podría tener lugar
en cualquier momento y podría reavivar
la violencia en el país donde la tensión
Aún es alta los dos bandos multiplican
los gestos de desafío el partido de
usmansonco y ama a los neganses a
intensificar la resistencia hasta la
dimisión del presidente denuncia una
depresión asesina por parte de las
fuerzas de por su parte el gobierno
reitera que mantendrá el orden público y
afirma que unos agresores bajo
influencia extranjera se mezclan con los
manifestantes por lo tanto la situación
parece completamente bloqueada a 8 meses
de las elecciones presidenciales esto
preocupa a los países vecinos y a la
comunidad internacional que llama a la
calma senegal suele ser conocido por su
estabilidad en una región agitada por
golpes de estado y amenazada por el
guiadismo pasamos ahora un tema distinto
las actividades ilegales de las empresas
chinas en República democrática del
Congo las conclusiones de las ongs
ecologistas son indiscutibles República
democrática del Congo que alberga casi
la mitad de los bosques de todo el
continente africano Sigue perdiendo este
capital de biodiversidad a un ritmo cada
vez mayor y el opaco sector maderero es
el principal culpable para hablar de
ello nos acompaña Gloria pallares
periodista que acaba de ser premiada por
la agencia de prensa F y el consorcio
público español casa África por una
investigación publicada en el país sobre
la explotación ilegal por parte de
empresas chinas en el norte de República
democrática del Congo Gloria
felicitaciones por su premio que le
llevó a interesarse por las actividades
de las empresas chinas en esta parte del
Congo y a llevar a cabo esta
investigación
de entrada me interesé por la selva del
Congo porque es la segunda mayor selva
del mundo después de la amazonía y sin
embargo es mucho más desconocida mucho
más desconocida para la ciencia para los
periodistas y para el gran público
entonces así empezó un poco mi interés
por las selvas de África Central luego
yo cuando fui a la República democrática
del Congo estaba radicada en la mayor
provincia forestal del país
y por lo tanto ahí el sector forestal es
capital para la economía y también de
algún modo hay presencia de sector
minero por eso empecé pues a seguir la
actividad de las empresas madereras y
también mineras y las especias de
árboles taladas se encuentran en peligro
de extinción y deberían ser protegidas
como hacen estas empresas para obtener
permisos de Tala
lo que ocurre en la República
democrática del Congo Y eso es un gran
problema que va más allá del sector
forestal es que como dice un experto uno
de los expertos a los que entreviste las
administraciones no las autoridades
gubernamentales a menudo lo que son es
máquinas de legalizar operaciones
entonces en el caso de la firmosia pues
lo que vi es que hay empresas que están
trabajando con permisos a la carta o sea
en este permiso se va a escribir lo que
ellas quieran eso se va a firmar no por
una autoridad competente no es un
documentos falsificados son documentos
Auténticos firmadas firmados por
autoridades locales Pedro el contenido
de esos documentos es totalmente
irregular por ejemplo dicen que en tu
concesión existe
abromosia Pero quizás este árbol no
en tu concesión ellos te han dado
permiso para vender x x metros cúbicos
ya promosia pero yo no lo tienes en tu
territorio Entonces qué vas a hacer o
qué puedes hacer lo puedes obtener de
forma ilegal de otras zonas de la
República democrática del Congo y con
este permiso lo exportas es una forma
por ejemplo de blanquear madera entonces
hay muchas argucias
para poder pues blanquear o legalizar
actividades que que violan las las
normas congoleñas y las normas
internacionales
y estamos hablando de un país
extremadamente rico con dos tercios de
los habitantes viviendo en la pobreza es
todo lo que acabamos de mencionar la
razón de ello
diría que una de las cuestiones quizá
que se desprende de la investigación es
que hay unos recursos naturales que son
un bien para los congoleños y son un
bien para la humanidad no deberían ser
un bien público y sin embargo se están
gestionando solo para el beneficio
privado para el beneficio privado de
algunas autoridades no digo de todas
pero sí de algunas autoridades para el
beneficio privado de algunas empresas yo
creo que ese es uno de los grandes
dramas de países como la República
democrática del Congo
muchos recursos pero unos recursos que
se explotan solo para beneficiar algunos
bolsillos privados Gloria Muchas gracias
por ser nuestra invitada pasamos ahora
del continente africano en Brasil uno de
los nombres más destacados de la nueva
generación de visuales brasileñas
Maxwell Alexandra presentó una
exposición llamada nuevo poder
pasabilidad en Río de Janeiro donde vive
y trabaja el artista rompe Con la falta
de representatividad y los estigmas
asociados a la identidad racial
la coloración del cabello para una
persona negra Está muy asociada a las
facciones de la droga en las favelas por
lo que acaba siendo un estigma que
representa peligro y refuerza la
violencia pero en los últimos años es
estética ha sido amada por el mundo y el
mainstream Así que hoy está un poco más
aceptada Por así decirlo pero la razón
por la que todos los personajes negros
de esta figuración de esta exposición
son rubios tienen que ver con la idea
del autorretrato que es como yo entro en
la figura negra
Reflexiona sobre el fenómeno reciente de
la figuración negra en el arte
creo que la representación negra es un
fenómeno reciente pero también ha sido
un fenómeno muy intenso cuando vas a la
feria de arte hoy en día ha predominado
la representación negra
creo que se ha convertido en una demanda
de Mercado pero es una manera que en
varios momentos es un poco el brazosa
pero es necesario y también es muy
importante decir que no es algo que se
regale es algo que se ha conquistado con
imágenes de la disposición Nos
despedimos gracias por su sintonía nos
vemos la próxima semana
[Música]